é nas em 1979 com uma doença
desconhecida que até hoje não tem um
diagnóstico fechado é mais ela
certa forma toda a musculatura do corpo
quando eu tinha dois anos de idade a
minha mãe me deu um carrinho de
brinquedo
eu me apaixonei pelo instrumento e aí
minha mãe percebeu que eu me esforçava
muito pra abrir as mãos para poder tocar
o instrumento porque eu não tinha os
movimentos das mãos é então ela começou
a procurar um professor que pudesse dar
aula pra mim e pelo e quando eu tinha 4
anos ela conseguiu achar uma professora
e aí eu sempre brinco falando que aí
começaram todos os meus problemas porque
assim nem esta professora e nem todas as
outras que vieram depois sabiam o que
fazer com uma criança que era muito
frágil que não mexia osmose direito e
que queria tocar piano
as pessoas tinham uma ideia é pra mim de
que o piano seria uma forma de
reabilitação passatempos e lá mas eu
sempre quis e pianista mesmo eu queria
ser artista queria seguir piano como
carreira os médicos diziam pra minha mãe
que era humanamente impossível é
adquirir um movimento para tocar piano
inclusive falar para minha mãe que
morreu dos 15 anos que tinha nada fazer
é mas enfim mas mesmo assim eu queria
ser pianista quando eu tinha 14 anos eu
fui estudando assim né meio alta de data
e pelo caminho e quando eu tinha 14 anos
eu conheci um professor chamado cláudio
tag que era super nos últimos 20 anos na
época e ele me viu tocando e falou que
eu era muito talentosa tinha que era
muito musical que ele viu o amor que
sente pelo instrumento e queria me
ajudar nessa questão técnica por tinha
dificuldades motoras
passei a estudar com ele e nós começamos
fazer um trabalho muito profundo é de
técnica pianística e com isso eu
adquirir todos os movimentos das mãos
para tocar piano mesmo os médicos
dizendo que era impossível isso
acontecer
com 16 anos eu passei a estudar com a
professora marisa lacorte que é uma das
grandes mestres do piano aqui do brasil
elas são paulo e com ela aprofundei os
meus estudos no instrumento e me tornei
a pianista que eu queria
aí eu toquei em várias salas de concerto
eu ganhei vários prêmios nacionais de
piano solo com orquestra e em 97 foi
para a rússia toquei lá e foi uma das
contempladas escolhidas para
para representar o grupo de pianistas
brasileiros que estavam lá na rússia é
muito bom
e assim fiz a minha faculdade de música
terminei com 20 anos a faculdade e com
21 resolvi entrar no mestrado para
estudar a educação musical e estudar
sobre processos diferenciados de
aprendizagem
aí nessa época me convidar para dar aula
numa instituição psiquiátrica nos
títulos não era uma instituição
psiquiátrica na verdade era uma
instituição que trabalhava com pessoas
com diversas patologias e nessa
instituição é quando eu cheguei lá eu
fui canção pessoa curiosa e gosta de
desafios
aí eu fui e quando cheguei lá eu me
deparei com pessoas muito estranhas
muito diferente do que estava acostumado
em termos de comportamento cognição tal
eu não tinha noção do que fazer eu
entrei em pânico e aí você precisa mudar
aí eu fui estudar sobre patologias
mentais cognição na série depois fui me
apaixonando pelo assunto e na verdade
que aconteceu é que eu comecei a criar
algumas atividades alguns jogos e
algumas alguns exercícios e alguns
materiais para utilizar com essas
pessoas
e aí como isso aconteceu umas coisas
estranhas assim as pessoas começaram a
mudar muito sim drasticamente então
pessoas começaram a diminuir medicamento
elas é pessoas que não conseguiu se
alfabetizar passaram a ser opção foi
batizada pessoas que eram muito
desorganizado em termos de atenção
passaram a se organizar e no final de um
ano tinha um grupo de alunos que eles
consideravam todos muito graves que
estavam em partitura tocando bonitinho
uma coisa por organizado e aí nessa
instituição nessa instituição eu tive é
uma história passei por uma história com
uma menina e que isso na verdade mudou
na vida profundamente e foi o que fez eu
mudar totalmente o rumo da minha
carreira deixar o piano de lado e para a
área de educação que eu conheci uma
aluna lá é que tinha 21 anos de idade e
ela não mexi em nada porque ela tinha
uma doença degenerativa que estava bem
avançada ela só mexia uma mão e mais
absolutamente nada e aí assim eu sempre
trabalhei
é uma questão assim em prol da autonomia
do aluno né
então nós montamos um grupo lá pra tocar
ea menina só conseguiu segurar o
chocalho marcar o seu sono chocado e tal
nós fizemos a apresentação no fim do ano
e aí no ano seguinte
é a gente entrou de férias no ano
seguinte
a turma voltou ea menina não voltou
porque ela tinha falecido nas férias é
porque era muito grave doença dela e
fiquei chateada tinha 21 anos na
primeira vez que eu tinha era a primeira
vez que tinha perdido um aluno estava
dando aula para a turma que era dela
quando de repente bater na porta e era
uma mulher ela me chamou lá fora com o
presente e ela falou assim eu sou a mãe
da menina que tinha falecido avô se eu
vim trazer um presente porque assim a
minha filha morreu muito feliz por causa
que é a coisa mais importante da vida
dela era essa aula de música
ela amava aula nova você analisa os
amigos dela e isso daqui de fato é muito
importante pra ela e eu quero te dizer
que assim é eu tenho certeza que ela
esperou para fazer a apresentação para
poder morrer desse jeito ter certeza
quero esperar fazer a apresentação para
poder morrer porque na noite da
apresentação depois que nós saímos daqui
ela passou mal foi para o hospital e não
saiu mais
ela falou isso que é semelhante
esperando para morrer a fazer gente como
está pra morrer
a frase em tom duro acontecendo aqui ia
começar realmente é em entender o
perceber não sei que eu tenho uma coisa
muito importante nas mãos que está
fazendo alguma coisa que que era muito
significativo né
e aí foi onde eu pensei comigo mesmo
assim eu tenho que entender o que é que
eu faço porque eu fazia as coisas
momento efetivamente dava certo eu não
tinha a menor noção do que estava
fazendo na verdade é essa
e aí eu fui estudar a frança agora tem
que estudar de verdade e eu pensei eu
preciso então entender a mente humana né
eu fui estudar psicologia e fugiu da
neurociência por conta a minha formação
praticamente inteira na vida sempre foi
autodidata e ea estudando por conta
acabei me apaixonando profundamente pela
neurociência e entendendo que talvez
janeiro daria algumas respostas para mim
e resolvi fazer o doutorado na neuro
terminei há pouco tempo um doutorado de
música
israel 6 é estudando tudo isso
neurociência filosofia psicologia sempre
gostei muito da é hoje eu entendo que
aquilo que eu fazia intuitivamente que
eu achava falando a gente acontece uma
bruxaria aqui porque os mesmos então de
um jeito e sai de outro todo mundo muda
e que está acontecendo aqui
aí aquilo que eu achava estranho hoje eu
entendo que o que eu fazia era era um
trabalho de neuromodulação ou seja o
trabalho para a cidade cerebral e as
pesquisas mostram que a música é o fazer
humano mais complexo que existe porque é
a música é único fazer que exige
praticamente todas as regiões
neurológicas ao mesmo tempo tanto das
regiões corticais que é nosso cérebro
mais refinado digamos assim enquanto da
sub-14 cais que que a parte do cérebro
que é mais antiga nossa é então por isso
que a música ela consegue tanto
reorganizar e trazer é essa a próxima
cidade será melhor para as pessoas e eu
entendi que com as atividades que eu
fazia era praticamente isso que eu
conseguia fazer com as pessoas e por
isso elas mudaram tanto o comportamento
de cognição uma série de coisas é hoje é
claro faço isso de forma muito
consciente eu sei o que estou fazendo e
é importante falar também que meu
trabalho ele não é de musicoterapia eu
nunca tratei ninguém não do diagnóstico
o meu trabalho de educação eu pego
pessoas qualquer pessoa de qualquer
jeito dólar de música só esse é o meu
trabalho
enfim é e assim eu faço muitas coisas eu
libero projetos eu dou aula eu toco
piano e desenho faz muita coisa
escrevo mas hoje hoje mesmo eu me
reconheço como educadora e por causa
disso eu trouxe cinco pontos importantes
para o ted que eu acho que todo
professora todo educador deveria pensar
profundamente sobre isso
o primeiro é que o olhar do educador faz
toda a diferença então eu penso assim
que o atrás daquele professor lá atrás
tanto o clube quanto a marisa né não
tivesse olhado para mim como pessoa que
tem possibilidade de aprender não para
aqui hoje os médicos o olharam própria
doença e para os impossibilitados e eles
olhar pros gosto que eu tinha pelo amor
que tinha pela música e pelas
possibilidades estavam ali
se eu não tivesse talvez olhar para
aquela menina que só mexeu nó como uma
pessoa capaz de aprender talvez ela não
teria esperado a apresentação né
para poder morrer então assim eu acho
que o olhar do educador é o ponto
principal e primeiro para que as coisas
possam acontecer segundo ponto educar e
aprender exige paciência persistência e
fé aprendizagem gente é uma coisa lenta
não tem jeito né eu acho que esse
aprendizado é como fazer uma colcha de
200 metros assim com uma agulha linha e
uma uma linha ponto por ponto essa coisa
que tem internet de aprenderem inglês em
três meses toque piano a 12 meses pelo
pela internet é possível né aprendizagem
exige tempo porque aprendizagem também
uma espécie de proximidade cerebral tem
que reorganizar o cérebro cria novas
redes sinápticos pra isso exige tempo
então um professor que não tem paciência
que não tem persistência que desistiu
dos alunos para minha pessoa que não
porta da sala de aula
o terceiro ponto o amor move mas quem
realiza o conhecimento quando fala de
amor
aqui eu acho que eu tô falando de dois
pontos o primeiro acreditou que o amor
tudo fazer o mesmo o amor pela educação
o amor que move você a áfrica até às
três da manhã montando material para ir
dar uma atividade que dura dois minutos
e você nunca mais aquele material sabe o
amor que faz você pegar um avião e lá
pra outro estado fazer um curso pra
voltar pra poder dar aula para um aluno
que nem sabe se vai continuar estudando
então o amor pelo fazer é muito
importante acho que a gente no ano que a
gente faz não vale a pena fazer nada
nessa vida né
mas eu tô falando de amor também no
sentido pode voltar frase é a primeira
eu tô falando de amor também no sentido
de vínculo afetivo as pesquisas também
mostram a neurociência já mostra pra
gente que quando a gente tem vínculo
afetivo quando tem prazer quando tem
leveza quando tem afeto com tem carinho
nas coisas que a gente faz isso
potencializa memória porque está ligado
ao sistema límbico
o gerenciador da memória que o hipocampo
tallinn no sistema límbico também da
mesma forma contrária se você tem uma
educação que é rigorosa terrorista um
professor que te dá medo e você aumenta
o nível de estresse esse nível de
estresse interfere no hipocampo eo
hipocampo
não não cristalizar as memórias e aí
você não tem aprendizado
então o amor é importante nesse sentido
também de vínculo afetivo com o aluno e
quando eu falo que é o conhecimento que
realiza porque eu também acho que tem
uma fantasia muito grande a gente que ai
só basta amar a educação e que as coisas
vão acontecer milagrosamente né e eu
trabalho muito com crianças que têm
deficiência isso outro direta em que ser
iluminado que pessoa boa que você é que
você faz e esse ano não tem nome nação
tem um trabalho que eu estudo muito para
conseguir fazer uma coisa né então é
óbvio tem um amor naquilo que eu faço
mas não é pela criança que é autista é
por pessoas e pela educação e pela arte
é isso que eu amo e então assim eu acho
que as pessoas precisam estudar mais
principalmente na área de educação e
principalmente em educação musical acho
que precisa aprofundar mais o
conhecimento porque eu acho que é o
conhecimento que faz com que as coisas
realmente acontecem ea gente não chegue
a um resultado interessante quarto
aprendizagem é um processo individual
intransferível
acredito eu que aqueles professores que
comparam alunos assim também não podia
estar na sala de aula né
eu entendo que se eu tenho 20 pessoas
dentro de uma turma eu tenho 20 aulas
que dou ao mesmo tempo porque assim cada
um que está ali é uma pessoa que tem um
potencial diferente habilidades
diferentes faculdades diferentes seus
traumas às suas expectativas para as
trações medos eu tenho 20 universos ali
eu preciso ter é eu preciso ter
sensibilidade suficiente para dialogar
com esses universos né então por isso
que eu acho que é individual e
intransferível que eu digo porque você
não tem como comparar as pessoas e
também eu acho que o professor nenhum
pode nunca na vida julgar o que é
importante para o outro quando era
criança praticamente as pessoas
decidiram que eu não ia tocar piano de
sigilo
então assim se não fosse muito teimosos
e também não tivesse uma mãe que
investisse muitas pessoas que
acreditaram em mim e não chega a lugar
nenhum então é eu acho que é sempre
importante
o professor ter essa visão de que a
educação é um processo e não comparar as
pessoas e por último educar é a arte do
encontro e até foi o tema da minha
palestra que eu acho que isso é o mais
importante
eu não acredito hoje que é primeiro que
ninguém ensina ninguém acredita mesmo
nisso segundo com o conteúdo é uma coisa
que eu acho que assim você entra na
internet você tem qualquer conteúdo
é muito bem mais dados do que eu falando
sozinho na sala de aula então eu entendo
que quando entra em uma sala de aula o
que eu estou procurando são pessoas e eu
estou procurando encontrar pessoas para
que eu tenha experiência troca de
experiência ea experiência ligado a
experimentar eu só consigo experimentar
quando eu tô na presença do outro eu
entendo que existe um espaço vazio entre
eu e outro né e é nesse espaço nesta
relação que a gente tem que investir
como educador porque eu entendo que
nesse espaço existem todas as
possibilidades todas as possibilidades
então tem a possibilidade de não dar
nada certo que dar muito errado de não
sair do lugar de não acontecer nada de
ser mais ou menos de ser muito bom de
conter um milagre
está tudo ali então depende da gente do
olhar que a gente tem eo quanto a gente
joga essa semente e rega
nesse espaço vazio né e então por isso
que eu acredito que a educação é a arte
do encontro
pra terminar a minha fala e eu consegui
cumprir o tempo que é uma coisa difícil
de se ted entendeu então pra terminar
minha fala eu gostaria de ela é uma uma
frase do paulo freire é um educador
brasileiro muito importante e com essa
foto que está aí que vocês estão vendo
que é de uma das minhas turmas aqui da
universidade federal já peço desculpa
para os outros alunos que eles vão vir
falar então com ciúmes mas assim eu só
podia escolher uma foto
então achei essa foto muito legal hoje
eu só entro na sala de aula para me
divertir se o clima daniela não foi esse
eu não dou aula e apa ea frase eu acho
que resume tudo que eu tentei falar
então pouco
o tempo aqui é a alegria não chega
apenas no encontro do achado mas faz
parte do processo da busca e ensinar e
aprender não pode dar-se fora da procura
fora da boniteza e fora da alegria é
isso muito obrigada
[Música]
[Aplausos]